[Music]
my name is Jagan karappa I'm a Technical
Account Manager within Google Cloud I
work with financial services customers
primarily and at the Technical Account
Manager my job is to make sure that my
customers are happy with everything that
happens on the cloud I do this through a
variety of different things one of the
things that I focus on is
high-performance computing and today
we're gonna talk a little bit more about
what that means for professional
services what that means for you hey
guys I'm Eric strategic car engineer
also working on financial services and
high-performance computing with Google
cloud as part of the professional
services organization we do help our
largest and most interesting customers
and partners get there so yeah so before
we get started we were pretty good at it
agenda plan for you today before we get
started I just wanted to give you a
little bit of flavor of what is Google
professional services we obviously go by
an acronym called PSO but the idea is
our mission is to get you is to get help
you get the most of the Google products
as you can see there's a lot of
announcement that come out from Google
there's a lot of things that you can
potentially do and a lot of different
products you can use our job as
professional services is to help you put
together all these products in some sort
of coherent story and help you get the
best out of the Google product system I
want to give you that flavor but before
we go in but most of the session is
going to cover a lot about how we can
help you in terms of agenda we want to
talk about five things today one is why
it's PC on GCP two is how you can do
this we have some blueprints for you
three years then we're gonna tell you
how we can help you we as professional
services and then we actually have a
customer that we've done this with who's
going to come up here and talk about
their experience with us and then we're
also going to show you what exactly we
did in customer so we have some folks
here our engagement leaders going to do
this work so it'll be a forum session we
have about 50 minutes so we'll go
through as much as we can and please
feel free to ask your questions at the
end
thank you thanks checking so first and
foremost why HPC and why do we run it on
TCP well you guys already know why you
need to have HPC workloads we're here to
tell you why do you want to on GCP but
just a little bit of recap anyway
compute needs are growing and I don't
think it's a surprise to anyone that
it's growing in this way all right
here's a growth chart of the top 500
supercomputers with the some of the
lists now exceeding one exaflop and XS
ecosystems are actually on their way so
while these are the leading systems the
rest of the HPC industry follows along
with the same trends and on the data
side not just compute side right with
HTC we also talked about data big data
we've been using that term for a long
time ten years ago when we had three
petabyte capacity systems we call that
Big Data now we're at 250 petabyte
capacity systems 10 years later and
we're still calling that Big Data so big
data is actually bigger than big and the
third variable in all this it's also
expensive look at all those numbers on
that time line on the left side and
running on Prem we also have that
limitation of how we can consume the
time that we need our workloads to run
and be processed is not really
predictable sometimes it's bursty and
with on Prem you're at with 100% we're
really forced to wait when we get to
this area right I thought one out of
compute and I have to put more things in
after waiting so lots of outlets
available and when I don't have a lot of
things to run I'm wasting money because
I still have to pay for that power to
run my own Prem systems so running it in
the cloud is a pretty good idea in our
opinion but what are the what are the
key differentiators for for Google and
why do we want to run on Google compute
storage and networking those three main
things on the compute side of things as
you guys all probably know how many of
you know that we have what we call
preemptable VMs right look at these are
vm's that we haven't sold yet and we're
like well they're sitting there anyway
why don't we give it to you at a
discount
rather super low cost and they're shorts
from instances and in order to make sure
that you don't use those VMs
crematoriums and in a bad way we
actually say you know what we're gonna
preempt them at least once every day
right this way you don't get used to
having preemptable Williams running long
term and then all of a sudden they go
away but what's coming up what's new we
do have some new VM families that are
available in EAP and that's compute
optimized VMs anyone interested in
cascade Lake processors 3.8 gigahertz
right that's coming and computer
optimized VMs you just heard that
announced during next today we have
memory optimized VMs this way we can
actually have two six terabyte and
twelve terabyte memory attached to two
VMs and in your processing nodes so this
is the exciting part of what's coming so
if we look at across the board of what
we've already brought a while ago custom
machine types what we brought a little
while ago right preemptable VMs quick
point-to-point VM to VM networks and
tomorrow we are bringing computer
optimized VMs we're bringing native job
scheduler integrations sole tenant nodes
for those chatty workloads that you have
and most importantly bringing all of
this from VM clusters to kubernetes all
of this is coming technology storage is
also a thing right most of the time when
you are running on Prem you're talking
about different data stores they
typically evolve around a shared file
system or other like um what else is
there what else do you guys went on on
Prem fir for storage lustre I last a
file we are partnering with all of these
different vendors out there storage
vendors to bring you a good storage
ecosystem as well and later we'll see a
whole slide of those partners and last
but not least the network on GCP we have
a fast Network right we have terabit
cross section 16 terrific cross section
network bandwidth inside our data
centers and you can actually have up to
7000 VMS per HPC for a reaper V PC
there's predictable latency across any
node across the globe and each VM
can actually take advantage of 16
gigabits of throughput so this is our
ecosystem right between storage workload
managers HPC applications and solutions
integrators that can help you get your
work load there I believe
HPC on GCP is the way to go feel free to
take a picture of this as well for a
link to any of the other sessions that
are HPC related here at next 2019 so now
we know why but how how do we do it well
what are some of the blueprints that we
have what are the common patterns that
we see HPC customers using on JCP you
can burst a cloud you can do auto
scaling right I don't always need to
have a static cluster of a certain size
and if I am streaming input to my
workload I can actually have that
cluster grow and shrink as needed so I
am paying for only the compute that I
need and not a cent more we can actually
also federate your compute workload to
the cloud only running in this way over
VP and her interconnects you can
actually have your schedulers and your
worker nodes on Prem and only when you
when you're on Prem Hardware is
exhausted and you need to go faster do
we need to go to the cloud so this is
another pattern that we see so putting
it all together we have a lot of things
here right number one we see external
feeds and cloud pub/sub as an example of
a streaming input to cloud storage and
cloud storage is our product where we
really stage all the inputs and the Big
Data to be used in these in these jobs
that goes in to your HPC farm right on
compute engine you can actually have
GPUs TP use as well as CPUs and this is
the part that we're talking about this
is the part that can scale up and down
and run computer optimized etc the rest
of the of the diagram that you see here
are really integration is with other
things so if you look at if you take a
look at number four after the HPC
perform processes everything and it puts
it back into a big storage area we're
gonna once again make use of Google
Cloud storage and from there you can
actually hook that up to bigquery
but that in archival storage and cold
line use that to train ml models and
sensor flow when you run HPC on GCP the
entire ecosystem opens to you and that's
what we're talking about but that said
how can we help you get there thanks
Rick
so as you saw in the last slide that we
have a lot of products and I'd mentioned
that earlier on that the Google
ecosystem is constantly growing
it's create and it's also challenging in
the perspective that you have to learn a
lot of new things on the fly basically
at all times which is a good thing but
when you try to build a solution it sort
of like gets overwhelming so we at
Google professional services sort of
believe in like building with you the
idea is that our HPC SMEs some of them
are with you right now our consultant
who you're gonna hear from and cloud
engineers like Eric himself we will work
with you to build this out
the idea is not like other consulting
firms where and we just come in and we
just do stuff and go away we believe in
this thing called crawl walk run it's a
JaVale understood term in the industry
but basically the idea is like pace
yourself as opposed to try to do
everybody wants to do something radical
everybody wants to do something really
cool and innovative but we want to try
to get something practical done first
and then you sort of go to the next step
so from an HPC perspective what we have
done with other customers where we've
been quite successful is first we come
in and we do some sort of questionnaire
and we work with your engineers HPC
engineers to understand the current
state what match scheduled ears do you
have what storage systems do you use
then we try to understand what that
means like what do you want to change
the six months then we develop a target
state for you and then we actually work
with you to build a proof-of-concept
this is a pretty interesting exercise
and I'll talk to you a little bit more
about it in the next slide but it's when
Google engineers actually sit down with
your HPC staff and your business folks
and we work with you to deploy your
workload on GCP how to set up the
network how to do
how to configure I am policies there's a
whole bunch of the stuff that has to
happen which we gonna help you with the
second piece is when you walk now that
we have you know the POC and you have
confidence in it what you're really
looking to do is to actually deploy this
so we have Google can professional
services can help but we have a whole
bunch of partners like our ORS and gft
there's a in the slide you saw that will
actually do this work for you if you
don't have the bandwidth to do this
typically we've seen customers go either
ways if you want to do it great if you
don't want to do it then we have
partners we can do it either ways and
then the final state is run and this is
where it gets really exciting for
customers is now now that you are in the
cloud and you have this deployed how do
you make the best use of the cloud so
the architecture that Eric was showing
you about is cloud native but that's
basically the power of the cloud is like
you get to try all these new products so
with that today we are launching a new
service we call it the first part of the
journey the crawl part of the journey
it's called cloud discover HPC this is a
service offering that we have been
piloting for the last one year we've
been fairly successful at it we have
done it with a financial services firm
that you'll hear from we've done it with
the healthcare firm we're doing it with
another big healthcare firm next week
and we've done with free edu we have
done about like 78 of these some with us
some with our partners we've gotten
pretty good at it I would think the idea
is that in the very first week what
we're doing is we do some prep work
before we get on the ground to
understand what your workload looks like
and all that good stuff then we actually
do a whiteboarding set then we come
on-site
on a three day effort wherein we sit
down with you we do whiteboarding
exercises to figure out what the target
state is and as soon as you do that
we're actually in code development mode
we're actually getting our hands dirty
with your staff and the idea is that we
want to leave the in three days we want
to build a POC and also like it's not
like we do the work and you say oh the
room fee you're actually sitting with
you and the idea is like we want to
teach you how to do this as opposed to
ask you this once this is done we go
back we understand what's been done so
far then we put together a technical
design document which is essentially a
plan which says ok now that this is the
POC how do you
this POC and how do you take it to the
next level it's a pretty good exercise
because what we've seen customers do is
they get their hands dirty with GCP and
all the different product sets out there
as opposed to just being like a a bunch
of slides and the second thing is do you
work get to work with real-life stuff
which is always exciting I just describe
this to you but just to go back on that
week zero is very much around like
preparation week one is planning and
then week two is designed for future one
thing I definitely want to call out is
we've had a lot of customers do this and
the part that really excites them is
that when the business comes up for the
use case let's say our calculations are
getting slower
we need more capacity whatever it is
this is a great opportunity for your
idea to get involved as well and we
actually sit with your IT and a lot of
enterprise organization in the business
an ID or two separates I want to say
silos but they're two different
organizations with two different
priorities right so this is one area
where the business has said something
and within five days you can sort of say
hey we built a POC
this works or this doesn't hopefully it
works and we can say that okay now what
so I know I've said a lot about how good
we are
I think it's it'll be helpful for you to
hear from our one of our first customers
so I'd like to call on stage Naveen
Malik he's the head of data for Cuba's
systemic he was one of our first
customers and now we will share all the
good and the bad that we had Thank You
Jagan first of all they're glaring
lights in front of me so if I'm not
looking at you I'm not ignoring you I'm
just trying to avoid the lights
sorry
okay so starting with the high-level
overview of our company Cuba's
systematic is the trading division of
0.7 t2 and point 72 is one of the
legendary hedge funds founded by Steve
Cohen in nine in 1992 the systematic
business was started early 2000s and and
that is the systematic business is now
called cubist so when we talk about data
any hedge fund typically uses a lot of
data but specifically the systematic
hedge funds which are other names are
like black box trading or whatever you
call it or quantitative trading they use
massive amounts of data because they
need this data to run their trading
strategies because these are hundred
percent automated systems we started
thinking about HPC a few years ago at
that time Google Cloud or HPC Google HPC
environment was not at that level we
tried a few other options which is come
out ASCO for today's discussion but I'll
talk a little bit about kind of where we
kind of went and how we set it up so in
general kind of any data processing
problem first of all it is going to be
i/o bound so a lot of people kind of
made the mistake of throwing a lot of
cores at it it's not gonna solve the
problem because if you're IO bound first
you need to solve the i/o problem io n
network so the way we solve the problem
is by building an in-house HPC
environment which was which used
utilizes a cluster based solution using
cheap magnetic disks with SSDs for
metadata and connected to through the
InfiniBand fabric to to compute nodes
and compute nodes are running contr grid
so this environment works pretty neat
for our requirements actually at that
time when we were
building this environment about three
years ago we knew there are going to be
some bursty workloads we thought okay it
will take us a week to from time to time
to rot to run through those bursty
workloads but for sustained workloads
the in-house HPC was was enough and
sustained workloads are what we had to
do day in and day out in terms of
processing the data as well as
delivering the data to the clients and
and I'll have a little bit more detail
on that so a question is why did we go
for or why did we choose Google cloud
and actually even more fundamental
question is why did we choose to go for
cloud so as I mentioned earlier the
in-house HPC solution works great for
our sustained workloads where the bursty
workloads that we thought are going to
be occasional actually turned out to be
a lot more frequent happens maybe once a
week a few times a month where we have
to go through some massive amount of
data processing and that creates a
problem for us because in that time
first of all the users are waiting if a
user has to wait for say seven days to
get their data that is an opportunity
lost they could have done something else
during that time so to deal with those
situations we considered other options
and then we decided to run a kind of
complete POC after getting an overview
of storage and network and compute
resources provided by Google so that is
sorry so as I mentioned earlier when we
are talking about HPC environments there
are a few fundamental components that
you have to worry about storage and
network are the most important one and
I'm talking about HPC for data
processing there might be other
situations where you just need compute
and you are good with it but for data
processing workloads you need to have
good storage which can keep up which can
supply enough data to your nodes and
network which can kind of deliver the
data and compute obviously but there are
two additional components which we were
very conscious about and I'm sure a lot
of you are going to be conscious the
cost and support so cost kind of it's a
lot of people think that cloud is cheap
but if you don't use it kind of in a in
a sensible way it can become very
expensive so we were very kind of
cautious about the about the cost we
wanted to be sure first of all what's
the storage is how the storage is going
to perform how is the network going to
be what are the costs for the compute
and overall what is the cost going to be
and support that's in any kind of
compute environment you want to have
very good support so speaking of support
as jagan mentioned earlier this PSO
organization was great it is a fantastic
team of engineers and developers and
Gabriel with his in his leadership he
brought together a really good team
which helped us set up this environment
so now I'll go a little bit into more
detail on the application or the problem
which was were testing the Google HPC
environment so we chose to use one of
the kind of problems which is level to
data processing and specifically which
was a CME this was just one of the more
established ones so we wanted to try
that one in a depth of book processing
you get massive amount of data in terms
of updates to the book and every update
to the book results in change of the
state of the book and more importantly
every message has to be processed in a
particular sequence so you have the
option to first logical thing is maybe
save the state of the book every every
time there is a change the problem is
there are large number of instruments
and every instrument can take tens or
hundreds of times every millisecond so
if you try to save the book state at
every update it will result in gigantic
amount of data and there's nothing wrong
with gigantic amount of data problem is
to retrieve it it's going to be
counterproductive in this case cm E is a
50 gigabyte compressed messages
nutus book state so compressed messages
every day and we had to go through 12
years of history so what was the
business objective of this particular
application business objective is to be
able to deliver book state for any given
instrument at any given point in time in
history so as I mentioned the messages
have to be frosted and processed in a
sequence from the opening time to the
point in time the user needs it so it is
very expensive to go through the whole
days of messages to to build the state
of that time for the given point in time
so what we did is we ran through the 12
years of history saved a snapshot of the
book every minute boundary and have an
API which you which recreates the book
at any given point in time so user
requests for an instrument ABC I need
data as of this time timestamp for the
book state as of this timestamp it finds
the previous minute snapshot and applies
the messages during that minute and
builds the bills and deliver the state
it does a lot more other things also
which kind of are outer scope for this
discussion
so during this result was we were able
to successfully duplicate our
environment in Google and not only
duplicate we were able to test the
scalability also as I mentioned earlier
in the slides first challenge is always
to kind of for a data processing think
about storage and and network we were ok
with that and then the problem that we
were having of being able to scale up
and down on demand that was resolved so
it was overall and we tested by spinning
up 400 compute nodes in-house we are
anytime we are running from 20 to 30
nodes and we did some experimentation at
there is some additional experiments
going on in terms of how much we can
push it can we run thousand two thousand
and how does the performance scale like
with any successful test a good customer
services service would ask for feedback
and jagan and Gabrielle asked me kind of
definitely put what should we improve
but we could have done better so as I
mentioned for for any client cost is
definitely one of the factors to worry
about and especially with the
preemptable that's a great idea I love
the idea the problem is it's hard to
tell how many PM tables are going to be
available at any given time so
calculating cost becomes a much more
complicated problem you can hope there
is going to be low cost because of
preemptable but you don't have an idea
where it is going to be so coming from a
quantitative background if my suggestion
is to make the either the history
available or just use the history run
some manual techniques on top of it to
kind of predict how many pre-emptive us
are going to get utilized for a given
problem so during the PSC we actually
had to run in the batches to see the
actual cost like after running it
instead of trying to estimate it ahead
of time
although kudos to Google for providing
the
excellent dashboard for looking at what
the cost is where the cost came from
where I came from storage from network
or from from computer and just so you
know the most of the cost was coming
from storage because we we wanted a very
high throughput storage that's the end
of the presentation by the way I'm
around if anybody has questions actually
we have a question as answer session at
the end I just wanted to mention I am
leading this cubist there are services
group and looking for good data
scientists software developers we are
not looking for hedge fund expertise
somebody is a good C++ developer we are
definitely looking for them so python
and so on and not only my group there
are many groups within within our
organization those who are looking for
good technologists we are competing with
Google Google for talent so if you are
interested in kind of looking kind of
working on staying in the technology
working on high-tech area and at the
same time learning about financial
industry there is an email address here
Cuba's talent at Cuba systematic calm
and and also you can look my contact up
from the speaker profile so at this
point I'll hand it over to Gabriel who I
mentioned was the lead cloud consultant
and TSO he was instrumental in making it
a success thank you so much all right
thank you
[Applause]
all right can we switch to the demo
all right thanks a lot all right in the
next 10 minutes or so I'm going to show
you how to deploy an HD Condor badge
scheduler in DCP so HD Condor is the
best scheduler that we deployed at
cubist as I said it was a good example
to to show you it's not the only
scheduler that we support in DCP there
is a learn PBS there is a whole bunch
what we will be doing now I will show
you how to deploy this using Google
deployment manager scripts so I'll show
you where to get the scripts how to
launch them and then the scripts will
deploy a what we call a submit host
where you can log in and submit your
jobs there will be a central manager
that will be used to coordinate and
match the jobs into the resources once I
showed you how to deploy the cluster I
will show you how to set up auto scaling
for your cluster with a solution that
will bring up nodes or down depending on
the number of jobs that are available in
the queue so let's start first thing I'm
going to get some software so I'll start
from here it's a software that you can
find in github GCP an HD Condor so these
are the three words that you need to
find the software and look here I'm
feeling lucky and the first hit is my
software now everything that I'm going
to show you is actually explained in
here so you can actually redo it
yourself but of course I'm going to show
you now to get the software so this is
github you can go to the repository you
can say clone copy the github link into
your memory and then you can say git
clone and here this will bring the
software into your cloud shell
environment I'm showing you my closure
environment I created a project
called HD condor demo to do that and
then of course since this is a demo I
have already downloaded it and so I can
go to where the code is so this is the
software that we are going to use to
provision the resources and then run
startup scripts that will install HD
Condor in the nodes this is the main
piece of software that you need to
configure to change the configuration of
of your cluster it's the Condor cluster
llamo so this is the list of files that
you have this is what you want to change
and you know the parameter are these
ones you have the number of nodes that
you want to have statically allocated
then you can scale them up and down the
type of resources that you want to
provision in this case I'm provisioning
nose which for calls each assigned to us
and then Condor version eight eight one
which is the latest I know this demo
works with this if you don't specify the
version you get the latest one so let's
get down to it so to kick it off you use
this command which is also explained in
the instructions as I was showing it to
you before and this will take the
configuration from llamó that we just
changed and deploy the resources you can
see what Google Cloud is doing by going
into your console and as you can see the
deployment manager is actually working
to deploy our resources you can see the
details of the resources that you are
provisioning here now we are deploying a
network and as the network is deployed
we'll create some firewall rules to
allow communication between
the demons on on-the-nose a twin stall
as I mentioned there is going to be a
master submit node and then a bunch of
computer resources so while we wait for
this to spin up let me tell you a bit
more about you know what what this is
right like when fast over this before
then to knows that we are deploying is
the submit and and central manager but
the compute nodes we will deploy using
what we call a managed instance group
now a managed distance group is a
resource in GCP that gives you the
ability of creating multiple identical
resources and so it provides an
interface an API that allows you to
specify how many nodes of that kind you
want and automatically it will bring it
up and down and we managed this group
also do other things like a rolling
updates and you know mora more than what
i'm just telling you but you know for
this demo we are only using those dos
api's so managed instance group is what
we are using to actually implement our
autoscaler so our autoscaler i can tell
you more now about that while we wait
for for these to come up well the
deployment has finished successfully now
you see that all of this is is up if you
go and look at your VMs you see them all
here what's happening now inside the VMS
startup script is running which is
installing HT condor so let me tell you
a bit more about the autoscaler while we
wait for this to install it takes about
a couple of minutes okay and this is
also a measure of how long you have to
wait when you bring up new resources so
you auto scale-up you submit more jobs
you also scare resources up in a couple
of minutes they are available to run
your jobs so how do you scale them up
you can go back to the same page as we
were before there is a directory called
autoscaler
if you click here there is a bunch of
instructions on how to set this up so
you can do that yourself I'll show you
how to do it what we are doing we have a
Python software that is called
autoscaler
not surprisingly we just accept all
bunch of different arguments documented
here what we want to do we want to go on
a node in this case we'll use the submit
node and install the software there and
then call the autoscaler with the
appropriate with the appropriate
parameters here so let's go to the
deployment let's see if it has finished
and then I'll show you how to install
the autoscaler so to go to the submit
node you can click on the SSH button
I'll bring up another one in case I need
it so what's happening now the system is
transferring keys so that to to the
machines so that then I can actually log
into the machines using SSH so this is
the terminal let me make it a bit bigger
okay so so what you see here is that we
have no jobs currently on the system
nothing is in the queue and that some
nodes are started to become available to
to report to it so what I want to do in
principle if I submit jobs these
resources will be able to render the
jobs for us what I want to show you now
is how to install the autoscaler
so first I need get that means don't get
all right and now the directory that you
want is in the same repo that I showed
before so you get clone this okay this
is the same direct the repository that I
have installed in my cloud shell before
now let's go to the autoscaler you want
to run this this program and what it
will do since there is no job in the
queue and there are resources in
available to run jobs if I run the
autoscaler now it will say well I don't
need all these resources let me let me
turn them off so let me cut and paste
this command here
this is the man that I did not want
I opened in case I needed it I I don't
think I need it
alright that's it the project name as I
said before is the HD Condor demo and
all the other parameters are fine now
I'm using the positive one what happens
is that the system will see that there
are more machines than jobs and it will
it will try to bring them now now one
thing that we can do we can submit more
jobs I have some example jobs here
applications this is a simple piece of C
code that calculates the first n prime
numbers
just as a way to use CPU and waste it
I'm going to show you the Condor submit
file this is the Condor submit files
that specifies how to run the program so
the executor executable is prime I'll
yeah let's calculate the first 400,000
prime numbers we don't have anything
better to do and so lets me run 12 of
those alright so i can submit it
all right so I have no resources now but
they have 12 idle jobs so let me run the
resources with the autoscaler let me
scale them up
all right so what's happening is that
I'm running I'm I have 12 jobs idle in
the queue I need to bring up three
resources to actually run these and so
what happening is that you know there
are more resources that are being
brought up because you know I need to
run them all right very good rather than
waiting until all of this is brought up
two minutes etc let me summarize what I
told you right so we have deployed an HD
Condor system in well about 10 to 12
minutes in in DCP I showed you were to
get the software you have to Google
github GCP HT Condor and surprisingly
you find a Google deployment manager
scripts there you can go to your cloud
shell and git clone that repository if
you go into the HT condor context you
can edit the parameters of your count of
your Condor cluster and then launch the
deployment manager so that you get your
resources up here once you have your
resources up you can use the cluster
that way or if you want to auto scale up
and down like we recommend then you can
go to the same one of the nodes they
submit no this is a good one and then
you get clone the same repo and then you
can put the autoscaler in an automated
execution fashion typically we recommend
to put that as a cron job maybe every
five minutes you can check or every two
minutes depending on your requirements
and automatically that will bring up and
down the resources as you need and with
this I finish my
[Music]